adam is he's one of a kind isn't he he's  a unicorn yes he really is he's a  unicorn because he's a joy he walks with  joy lives with joy and he doesn't get  moody yeah comedians are moody and i'm  attracted to them because i want them to  make me laugh in real life yes and let  your girlfriends do that yeah  totally yeah okay so there was this uh  twitter debate that happened about who  is a better partner for adam sandler  jennifer aniston or drew barrymore which  sounds weird to say my name  and what i loved about what came out of  that was what  well that you and i chose each other oh  well that's a no-brainer  yeah  that's because you know the there's the  the the phrase the guys like to say you  know bros before hoes oh my god i was  gonna say hoes before bros always  and that is sisterhood